[Music]
all right up this week a quiet place now
before we get into it because sure
enough I talked I was sure there's going
to be some controversy sharing this film
and of course because you have to ruin
all the things it is now it's offended
people before we get into that right
away the writing we both give this a
mug's up hugs up two mugs up a quiet
place hardly absolutely we both enjoyed
it I'll get into what I liked about it
what I didn't basically I will say this
there could be some spoilers here we're
gonna try and avoid it but we can't make
any promises no cuz the say the second
we do issue a spoiler it's gonna be just
lighting up the comments section but you
haven't seen it by now you're now other
there are plenty of people haven't seen
it but I don't know I don't know if it
gets to China or not I have no idea
probably not I have no idea but you can
leave your what did you think of the
film if you liked if you didn't in are
you aware the controversy surrounding it
let's bring it up spend computer than
controversy now people not necessarily
thrilled with what they see is a pro-gun
message pro-life message the regressive
politics they hate all the things this
is just and I knew it was coming because
as soon as I walked out of the film we
talked about this yeah
all of these criticisms by the way from
from the left and these blogs and here's
the thing Krasinski's no no he's a
liberal and Sosa's wife Emily Blunt so
you know they'll probably be on an
apology I think she said some things
about like an unlike in America before I
think she's been pretty open about yeah
so you don't want to flip-flop on
whether you you don't like stars and you
don't like their their art or their
performances based on their politics the
point is this is not something that they
expect it I don't think they set out to
make a movie like this that being said
if you're looking for it
all those criticisms would be valid yeah
and we were talking about this the film
um yeah let's cycle through them it
absolutely for people who've criticized
it for being too pro-gun it is it could
be seen as very pro-gun namely because
how else to kill giant monster creatures
with superhuman hearing if the film were
anti-gun it would be a pretty short
movie so when you watched this film I
was watching it with my producer Johnny
boy said yeah this film does seem does
seem pretty pro-gun it absolutely does
if you're watching it you can there's no
other way to take it Jared you can come
we can roll those up steroids but what
did you did you see this when you watch
the film I did I was really aware like
the whole way through I'm like there's
so many angles they could have taken to
get get out of it too
yeah like the the pro-life message
didn't like they didn't have to have a
baby that's another one it was
absolutely pro-life so yeah
spoiler alert Emily Blunt is pregnant
and that yeah so this is a major so a
major spoiler alert three two got it
okay good she opts to give birth while
there is one of these MA and this sort
of I guess you'd say it I guess it's the
climax of the film yeah
giving birth with this monster thing in
the house having to stay quiet going to
the pain of protecting her her kin and
actually they build a box for the baby
to live in and they give it a whole gas
oxygen tanks with the baby if it cries
it won't be heard nice people won't be
killed kinda reminiscent of sort of
babies who would cry in the Holocaust
you've heard those stories yeah the very
first scene in the film is at a pharmacy
there could be a poison poisoned so I'm
like there's a million ways that could
have gotten out of that situation and
but they didn't right was it I mean
there's a lens up to the movie sure but
it's it seemed intentional well it
overall can certainly be seen as a
pro-life message certainly listen this
is kind of more so it's toss and heaping
coals on the head salt on the moon
pro-family pro-christian I don't think
it's necessarily actively those again
none of this is proactive but they do
pray at dinner and it's not mocked which
is very rare for a film so I could see
how again we're watching it going like
oh they're just saying a prayer before
dinner and that's it yeah whereas I can
send one at salon watching it going
they're saying a prayer before dinner
and that's it but I'll be all on the
other line or better be a commentary
about how pedophiles aren't monsters on
the next reel when I see those burn
marks I want to see some kind of gender
non-conforming pedophile so and it was
pro-family just just through the mere
fact of a father was taking care of the
family and it was a tightly knit family
so yeah pro-gun pro-life pro-family I
can see it certainly Pro patriarchy
absolutely this is one thing out this is
a it is almost I mean I could see how
the Lufkin see it almost comical this is
the the quintessential patriarchal
family strong father figure it's never
seen as a negative by the way no and
you're something else that's a very
important to know it's still a very
strong female character absolutely this
isn't a woman that doesn't a fake you
know atomic blonde hitting someone with
a stiletto which would do absolutely
zero other than piss somebody off is a
strong female character who spoiler
alert takes out some of the monsters is
basically a mama bear protecting her
children but also goes to hell herself
too goes through how absolutely herself
and comes out stronger it but but
submissive kind of in like the biblical
sense to her husband in the sense that
the husband says listen I'm gonna go do
this get this done take care of the kids
this way and then I'm gonna go to this I
need you to stay here and do a B C and D
if she were feminist it'd be a short
movie if the wife were to question
everything the husband says the pay it
would be a short movie and at no point
do you sense that there's any kind of
animosity because of a strong father
figure who's trying to provide no and
it's not as though she's weak and she's
a secondary character this is what we
call as Christians complementarianism
they're both equally important but they
serve two different purposes and I can
absolutely see how if someone on the
Left watching this film they would see a
pro patriarchy message because it's kind
of there um and this is one thing I will
say this is kind of proof positive that
I've talked about there's a
conservatives and in sort of right-wing
ideas make for better films if you think
about all the things that make that look
at the top movies of all time we can
bring that up conflict good and evil
justice personal responsibility
overcoming adversity these are themes
that we've always talked about on the
right that we believe in and these are
themes that people really resonate with
if you look at a lot of the films that
have done really well when Hollywood
can't fully understand it this is why
there's now a disconnect between the
awards films and the films that people
go and see now there is popcorn crap as
well absolutely and I would not say this
is a lot of I would not say this is
popcorn crap no this is a good film but
that's I think what there's an
increasing disconnect between the
entertainment industry and people in
United States yeah I think I think
you're actually right um can you imagine
for a second a film like this if the
carriers and will be acted the way
leftists advocated so you have self
sacrifice for example from the main main
actor Junction ski I forgot his name in
the film basic white guy name to save
his children's baby would have been way
easier to abort the baby of course
there's no good and evil no conflict who
cares about the film this these films
like this the films that people really
resonate with it's it's not only about
overcoming adversity and personal
responsibility but it's about overcoming
adversity it's about it's it's human
nature this is kind of an irony that
we've talked about people who are upset
about this patriarchy hear people talk
about gender societal conditioning films
are very reflective they're supposed to
kind of play an emotional strings that's
what they're designed to do particularly
a scary movie fear is a very basic
primal
emotive response it's a very visceral
emotive response to an emotion and then
it translates to actions how people act
out of fear and
case um this is this the only will try
to recondition anyone are the people
saying that all of gender that all of
our basic instincts our society
conditions the people trying to
recondition if using eyeless and toxic
masculinity like what this this film
Todd no that's this is very basic a man
wants to go out and sacrifice himself
first so a man wants to go out be a
hunter-gatherer protect his children and
guess what a mom wants to protect and
nurture yeah this is this is why it
resonates with people because you watch
it and you feel something really evil
don't mom I got what if that were my kid
oh my gosh well if you're a kid going
what if that were my dad
oh my god what if I were primont watchin
- oh my god she's pregnant and they feel
that it resonates with them and we're
told from the left that this is societal
conditioning well they are in fact try
to recondition us they're trying to
recondition us from our most basic
instincts you go to you find the Hutu
tribesmen out in the plains of whatever
country that doesn't even exist so don't
try and fact check that you're going to
see father's protecting hunting
gathering and mothers being nurturing
and mothers being violently protective
of their babies and that's what you see
in this film yes absolutely um and I
think it's uh III think you're gonna see
people look for a groundswell of unhappy
people retro actively giving negative
reviews now and probably an apology tour
from John Krasinski and Emily Blunt
because like I said you see all it takes
is one review and then you find eight
well yes today's you know back street
blogs or tomorrow softball front front
page so right you I think you're gonna
see that start small start little and
then just explode into yeah exactly
well you know what they might have a
point they're gonna have breakout panels
you know about about the the CSE's that
occurred from people watching this
because they felt as though this woman
it was she was obligated to bear the
child like it really does it does hit on
and I will say you know one film that is
just the most blatantly pro-life film
that I've seen in a long time is brawl
on cellblock 99 with Vince Vaughn I
can't believe that that was an accident
but I do think it's a lot easier for
leftists to accidentally make
conservative films you don't really see
the opposite again it's it's really easy
to make a film that deals with conflict
personal responsibility that deals with
overcoming adversity look at every
single big film that people love that's
the this this is the triumph of the
human condition that's what makes movies
interesting successful liberals if you
look at John Krasinski or Emily Blunt
they're liberals they haven't lived the
what what was the views Davis paused
none to you John Krasinski got rejected
no no no it's a tough racket to be an
actor like that that guy failed picked
himself up by his bootstraps and is a
rugged individualist he doesn't
necessarily believe that everybody else
can do and know nobody's been successful
lives by the rules of no you can't you
can't it's possible is it's
self-defeating exam and people people
want to be people create this is another
human instinct people create teams
people create villages they want to have
communities but they want to be
independent human beings naturally do
not want to be dependent on another
human being that's not a triumphant
story it's not a triumphant story for
someone to walk in and get a handout and
that's the end of the film it's a
triumphant story for the man to overcome
adversity or someone to not overcome
adversity and someone else to carry that
torch as you see in this film so I will
say about this movie just as far as why
I really liked it it was it was scary it
was paced well yeah the acting was
really good it was well directed but I
will say this it is absolutely a series
of gimmicks after another that are very
effective I don't mean that necessarily
in a bad way
but you remove that and you remove the
ability for the film it makes sense a
little bit up though yeah I mean I mean
I definitely mean in a way like someone
sat down was like okay how can we kind
of manipulate the audience with these
these I would say crutches a little bit
but they use them well so I want to stab
people around me eating popcorn
won't stop myself eating popcorn yeah I
can quiet yeah
what are you any thoughts you just
beyond yes or no
yeah let's pretty much where I'm at okay
amazing clouds thanks I appreciate
preciate your contribution they're not
gauged you know I do think that
absolutely it's a film we're seeing it's
kind of gimmicky and so like you know
you know the basic premise right of
course people have to be quiet okay then
you find out what and then each scene is
oh okay maybe there's a flooding scene
maybe oh now there's a superhuman
hearing oh now oh maybe this person
doesn't have any hearing and so it is a
use of gimmicks for scheduling I will
tell you what makes you really
appreciate a film like this is when you
watch it and then you go watch it
terrible scary move oh yeah you go and
watch a scary movie that doesn't work at
all you realize just how hard it is to
do so two mugs up for a quiet place did
you enjoy this video here's the thing
you wrote you're here this is the end of
it so we don't care because you already
watched it but if you really didn't like
it and you want to justify it leave a
comment below telling us why you didn't
like the video and if you liked us let
us know and subscribe to the channel
because
let's the overlords at YouTube know that
you know what you're alright